ah I came from underneath never done
before.i II like to innovate I like to
try different things
thank you for watching the Peter Pyle
greatest channel on YouTube look I even
do zoom the stuff how about that you see
anyone else do this huh I also do
private bookings now it's time for me to
review your reddit submissions last week
I asked you to post a picture of
yourself so that I can roast you because
every damn time it's like so I challenge
you to post a picture of yourself so I
can roast you Oh what is this
the other two bones Eddie you're gonna
leave opposed Eddie I can't find a
single one you bunch of [ __ ] you
bunch of crybabies I bet ya you're all
talking no play you know soon as I come
wrestling hey boys what's up youko you
go runnin you go runnin it's almost like
I've never ever in my whole life has
someone a hater in real life huh it's
always oh I love your channel and you're
[ __ ] right you want to wrestle boy
that's right I'm Swedish fine punch you
well we're gonna review the memes the
PewDiePie means the unholy trinity can I
join this meme can I force myself into
this meme I gotta do a funny face it's
missing something
I really have nothing how about this
YouTube's recommended a page for the
past hour
well it sounds like you're a rut lucky
man you'll get to watch the best content
on YouTube regularly very sad hey look
it's a Wall Street Journal mean who
would win a multi-million dollar company
from Kristin Swedish boy I'm a Swiss
tchen I'm a Swiss join everyone you
don't mess with a Swiss Peter pie you're
irrelevant don't try to roast back
unless you want a diss track should he
pull that there your relevant card I
don't know he's perfect he's perfect
okay he's perfect what K I can't say
anything don't make fun of my opinion
what's the context of this picture I see
it being posted everywhere I don't
understand 2012 markiplier was the best
damn markiplier and I keep telling you
can someone photoshop my beard on top of
markiplier 's head please begging you it
will look good I promise when Felix
started putting dolphin noises over his
cuss word this is what's happening
behind the scene no I'm putting dolphin
noises in because I'm a Christian
channel on my own free will I'm not as
one of these fake Christian channels
that all the sudden when the apocalypse
happen everyone was like oh I am family
friendly guys I've always been I've been
family friendly since day one and
everyone knows that he's faked Swiss
chinch I'm a true Swiss Jim okay in
Sweden we literally have Felix meatballs
yeah you had to bring that up didn't you
you had to bring that up
do you know how much bullying I had to
endure because of that brand Oh Felix oh
why don't you make some meatballs I'm
not making meatball
Oh Felix you're in the ketchup they had
the slogan no that was like Felix makes
the tasty tastier you know what they
would tell me Felix
makes disgusting disgusting er hey we
all got to survive the apocalypse
somehow okay wait what is this yo it's
your voice thick Szechuan here hoping
you guys can help me I want to gift some
sauce you might recognize me as the
douche by hipster guy who gave away his
winning sauce during Sichuan apocalypse
well the other day PewDiePie future me
in his video yeah I had to take the
video down because it got copyrighted
because some music was in it I have no
idea so he wants to send me the Szechuan
shot my god
better yesh there's only a little bit of
Szechuan stops left get that man get
that man right now I'm sending my
minions go forth my Swedish minions my
swing Ian's get that last bit of sauce
before it's too late you just want to
remind you guys that I asked you to post
pictures of yourself just a small
reminder there in case you forgot
oh here's actually one dear Peter pie
the gap between your lips and your beard
is almost as far as the gap between your
sub can't and your view count your turn
do your worst is this man serious right
now he's making fun of a gap and he has
the biggest gap between his teeth I have
ever seen
but wait so you think that's what I'm
gonna make fun of but no it's a trap
it's a well-placed construed trap
enhanced a photo it's a fake gap he
placed it as a trap well done well
played well played you know what I'm
just gonna go ahead and say it you
dressed like a lesbian and that's not a
microaggression
that is just fact I was at school and we
were at the beach and I turned around
and saw Croatian
stop taking pictures of strangers and
sending them to me it's weird it's
really weird it happens all the time I
feel really bad for all these pewdiepie
wannabes okay they're never gonna be me
and they just have to deal with it so
stop giving them an outlet to continue
what they're doing I may not have 50
million subs but I do have 50 megabit
upload speed you ask me why you have to
go there got to go there huh Wow Wow
disgusting okay first the Felix ketchup
sauce and now the Internet
you guys know my weakness damn it this
is cheating I'll take 50 million subs
overlooking 50 any day thank you very
much god I'm Christian Channel Beauty
Savage
yeah why the heck was set 21 savage with
Jake Paul I don't get it you need a cup
holder I got a cup holder yeah you wanna
DJ yeah you know what I'm a DJ you
always doing the music stuff Oh 21 you
always do the music stuff because you're
a musician how many drugs do you think
he took to endure this I really
appreciate the nipples sneaking out
there no no no that's not Christian stop
it stop it ah the ketchup god damn it ha
ha ha damn it I didn't worry today I
always wear the damn tracksuit I look
good man I look good you can't deny that
I look gay my crew is big and it keeps
getting bigger
that's cuz Jesus Christ is my neighbor
Thank You Christian channel thank you
what the hell don't post my memes okay I
posted it on Twitter already
I stole the content before you stole the
content which officially means we
reached a full 360 of content theft I'm
real proud of you guys honestly I'm real
proud ha ha ha I'm not gonna buy no
chair I can just DIY Maya huh that
doesn't look very nice and I do I can
hardly see the tape on the sucks
excellent I need a machine to walk but
at least I don't need a fan base to make
content
hey it looks like your looks like you're
sitting though am I the only one who
noticing this is that you're not really
walking there buddy oh my gosh that's
cool I love this Fenner I hope mr. P
deep eyes see this fan of man I really
like it I'm so pissed I had to read
delete that Rick and Morty video it was
so good I really liked them damn it
your ears look like the ones of our
necks change Chancellor and you didn't
even get them to fly Marcia and you to
be in yeah my ears this does look kind
of weird isn't it it looks like a weird
vagina how is that a bad thing okay
these men were arrested for cooking
vegan meatballs in public oh I see you
think I look Amish just because I have
this beautiful beard okay
this beer is ten out of ten ten out of
ten there's no imperfections all right
well you have a little gay up there
Oh it's intentional okay that's how God
gave me to me
and I'm thankful Christian Channel okay
there's nothing wrong with this beer if
theirs was an IQ contest I bet you I'm
Rick and Morty and you're Dora the
Explorer
Rick and Morty IQ 23 IQ Dora the explora
No where is this from when you kill
those races yes unintentional NEMA fide
thank you very much how do you find
these seriously I'm impressed
this is you laughs you lose pewds this
is the seventh week in a row you've
shown your laughs you lose in class if I
ever stop your life you loose that's
when you need to worry okay that's when
you know I'm truly given up so you
should be thankful that they're still
you laughs you lose
Thank You say it Lopez make original
content
these unoriginal content jokes are
unoriginal though that's right
someone who's woke you know what I bet
Christus the nerd say I bet the one who
made this meme it's a Swiss chin well
done well then okay you did it applause
okay okay okay
that was it for this week's of PewDiePie
shitty means you clearly failed
completely so I will give you an okay
you get a no kick because the memes
we're still good next week I want you to
submit an audio clip okay it can be
anything it could be anyone whatever you
want send the audio clip and I will
review it and as always send the
repeated repeating memes and I will
review those as well this has been squad
fam number one sweet stream channel best
channel on YouTube 16 billion views
untouchable and smack it up back